Hello friends,
hey, it's great
that week,
or rather,
Mr. Pérezés,
the President of the neighborhood,
decided,
dissolved for the sale of,
to call new elections for May 12,
because the budgets that had to be approved
for 2,024,
budgets
expansive with more than 1 increase of 1 6 per 100,
basically,
a Cost of 1 higher tax burden,
obviously,
and budgets that were intended to create
no less than 7,300 public jobs
on 1 elephantiasis and hypertrophied administration
and in Iranian administration,
were not approved.
And to do so, he requested
always that policy
psychological which is that of victimhood,
that is,
search for other people's phenomena,
strangers,
in other people or on buses,
excuses for justification,
to justify
their incompetence to govern
and to manage public administration.
It is this victimhood that has always,
historically,
The independentistas have used it,
and which is attributed,
barely from,
as Joaquim Torra,
Carlos Puigdemont,
Arturo mas and Jordi Puyol,
to all victimhood.
But of course,
as a result of this victimhood
we do not realize it,
and many times angels do not realize it
that there are real victims
You call to the,
to the,
to the action of 1 executioner,
and Look, for me,
1 executioner.
The executioner is very clear,
is the Catalan autonomous administration,
and generality of Catalonia.
And the victims,
for there are many,
and we are going to name you succinctly.
To begin with,
the entire ceocatavana society,
every Catavana society,
is a victim of the policies of the different governments
separatists is 1 society that has been impoverished
in the last 20 years
inexorably,
is 1 company that is tax-exposed.
In Malaga we have the sad record
of having 14 taxes that do not exist in other countries
autonomous communities.
In Malaga we have the sad record
that inheritance tax
is the most expensive in Spain,
that with premeditation and greed
Mr. Torra's government
in Good pandemic of 2020,
specifically in May 2020
increased it by 7,
for that of course there are more deaths,
more income.
Because of course,
logically the peel is the peel.
and where on the other hand
rents between 30,000 and €60,000,
i.e.,
2nd
are the most fiscally punished.
Catauña is a society where they are also victims.
from eh
of the 3 governments of these separatist governments,
of those eh incapable
governments to manage the Republican administration,
the entire teaching system is also victims.
To begin with,
Catauña has 1 sad record,
another record of 0 to autonomous community
which has had worse evaluations in the pisa survey,
and we have the problem that conservative teachers,
who are largely excellent professionals,
are crammed with tasks
practically political,
that they are incapacitated,
that limit them to what is truly
its function,
which is education,
and within the teaching staff,
within education
are also victims of those students and,
above all, of
those parents
That eh taking in
to what is required by the law that 1
25% of academic works
for parents who require it
Be made in Spanish.
The history of Catalonia,
making USE of 1ial language policy,
passes it through the lining completely
with the support of the conservatives' social parties,
and ignores court rulings
in favor of this right that these parents have,
their victims.
of this Great Executioner who is the western one of Castile,
all farmers and ranchers speak Spanish.
there is 1 indication of weather cause,
to some extent true,
but not D.O. all true,
and much less by saying that it is of anthropogenic cause,
as progress says
Independence.
But it turns out that governments
of the recording scene
They have opted for 2 solutions to avoid impunity.
First increasing,
increasing taxes on water.
You tell me what,
what, what,
what what.
What more coercive measure should I imitate it?
Or water consumption.
And on the other hand to fail.
Failure to have in endowing
a Construction of 1 true infrastructure
to solve or at least limit
the effects of radiation.
Look, you love it.
1 during those last 30 years
hardly anything has been invested in modernization,
in the updating of water pipes.
Every day they are lost
million cubic meters of water
due to poor condition of the pipes.
As if that weren't enough,
we have the largest river in Spain,
which leads to failure,
which is the Ebro River,
that it issues every day
millions and millions of cubic hectometers into the sea,
but that for electoral reasons
remember that when it was done
when the National Hydrological Plan was drafted in 2004,
was automatically repealed
by cobbler government
with the support of the independentistas,
was repealed for purposes or for purely
ideological.
And so we have as the alebron bum cannot be touched,
lest we authorize or modesty
to voters in the lands of Tarragona,
of D.O. Bashkam,
D.O. munchía,
who are voters of Esquerraa,
and instead
we have to import desahunized water
from the Valencian Community,
from the Port of Sagunto,
when on top of
we have desahunizers in,
like dadebanes,
which is 50% off its performance,
that is,
let's go Casquiano,
are victims of this executioner,
which is rationality.
Also all homeowners in Moscow,
look at those who expose in alquiveres,
They have subjected in according to which areas,
to 1 interventionist policy,
the most interventionist
regarding the cauco of the alquiveres
that occurs in Spain,
but if it is on top of that.
it turns out that these homes do not want to activate them,
can be fruit or can be USE of 2 occupants.
Because in Moscow,
another sad record
holds the record of being the Spanish community
which takes 40 and 9%.
of the total number of occupations occurring in Spain.
All thanks to these governments
progressives and independents,
in the last 15 years,
the generality of Catalonia
are also victims of these separatist governments.
All normal people
that eh see as the cities of Moscow,
the different neighborhoods of their cities
are increasingly objects
of 1 increase in crime.
and for sure it was 1 increase in crime,
because in to more we are observing
1 increase
of illegal immigration fees.
Today the immigrant population in Romania
represents almost 20 percent of the population
in some cities,
in some neighborhoods is more than 1 50%.
The inhabitants living in those neighborhoods,
in those cities of all life,
today they have problems
to be able to go down to buy leopansis,
that his lifelong still exists,
simply because it is 1 fruit of robberies,
of theft and other major crimes
Thanks to the connivance
of Catalan separatist governments.
In the event that in Moscow you die
is also not only expensive
so he was able to leave heirs,
but on top of that if you die in
in a position to have ordered 1 Audi from dependence,
as the conservative administration
works so efficiently,
50 percent of the people who lived in Moscow
having requested 1 independence aid,
still without having received it
Thanks to agility
of our administration.
I have a case of 1 relative of mine.
who requested the application of euthanasia,
died and the permit was revoked
3 months after Death
of death
3 months later.
Shameful,
embarrassing.
In Catalonia they are also victims of nationality,
the entire health system,
1 collapsed health care system,
simply collapsed
because it is overused,
is otherwise poorly managed,
where, on the other hand,
doctors are lacking,
pediatricians are missing,
lack of toilets
and where,
on the other hand,
the health personnel
working in
is more poorly paid
than in the remnants of other communities.
And on top of that we have thety
to impose in the Catalan language
to many professionals
doctors and health care providers coming from Latin America
and that the Catalan administration imposes on them.
How curious,
the USE of Catalan in its practice
eh daily assistance.
They are also victims of that of the landslides,
of Japanese.
You are one of those people
looking for a living society,
1 society in Peace,
because to them precisely,
that is,
to the independentistas,
are interested in,,
create agitation,
create harmony,
like this
to make people,
to weaken,
weakens society
and they take advantage of these Manichaean policies.
are in short
victims of the islet of.
All companies
that they are subject to tremendous obstacles,
to very high tax burdens
and without any legal certainty.
In fact,
since 2 017
thousands and thousands of dams have left the catona
and will not return.
Look in legal courtesy,
today more than ever
that is created in this region.
Anyway, friends,
Check out your May 12th,
we already know who IS going to win.
Independentistas will win because they have 1 law
favorable election for them.
From the moment 1 vote in Tarragona,
in the lands of al Ebro,
is worth more than 4 months more than 1 Barcelona vote.
Of course,
we will already know
who IS going to win and on top of that they give you support
of the bugle on duty,
never better said to be the socialist party.
Nothing WILL change.
What I am telling you is 1 thing
and that I have been repeating for years,
cataduña, Spain,
but cataduña in particular
is progressively approaching
to 1 dead end,
to 1 dead end.
Thank you friends and tomorrow will be